à la périphérie de la ville de vous les
Dar
ces soldats Ukrainiens n'entendent céder
aucune parcelle de terrain mais en face
à quelques centaines de mètres la
pression des forces russes augmente
comme partout dans le Dombas ça n'a rien
les attaques d'artillerie et de mortiers
de l'ennemi ont augmenté c'est
auparavant il y en avait quelques-unes
mais maintenant il y en a plus de 10 par
jour
il ne faut pas sous-estimer l'ennemi on
ne peut ignorer le fait que l'ennemi
remporte des succès modestes mais
significatifs dans ce qu'on appelle les
batailles d'importance locale
urbains s'intensifient les troupes
russes avancent malgré la pugnacité des
soldats ukrainiens
Moscou lance une nouvelle offensive à
quelques jours du premier anniversaire
de l'invasion
la situation sur la ligne de front
notamment dans les régions de deniers et
de Louans qui restent extrêmement
difficile c'est littéralement une
bataille pour chaque maître de terre
ukrainienne beaucoup d'habitants se sont
réfugiés dans le village de jasy Viard à
15 km de bac mouth au lexander a vu sa
ferme détruite par les combats mais
continue de garder espoir
je ne serai de retour dans un mois ou
deux et peut-être même plus tôt parce
que les Russes ne sont pas rond jamais
de parkmouth cela n'arrivera jamais nous
le savons dans nos cœurs pour le moment
nous attendons mais ensuite nous irons
semer nos champs car la nouvelle saison
arrive le groupe Wagner a revendiqué
dimanche la prise de krastagora dans la
banlieue de backmouth mais selon son
chef Eve guini Prigogine la ville de 700
000 habitants avant la guerre est encore
loin d'être conquise